ANTHONY: There's going to be
some killing happening.
Killing bacteria.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUEST SPEAKER: If you've ever
taken antibiotics, you've
probably swallowed this
molecule, or something like.
This is penicillin g.
Today in 5.301, the students
are going to
split up into teams.
Each team will react 6-APA,
that's this molecule, with a
different acyl chloride, making
a different kind of
penicillin.
Tomorrow, the teams will test
how good their penicillin
derivatives are at
killing bacteria.
Phil hands out the different
acyl chlorides.
Even though his instructions
are clear--
PHIL: Anything that has acyl
chloride on it, in the hoods.
GUEST SPEAKER: Tengfei soon
notices something.
ANTHONY: Do you smell it?
LINA: Smells so weird.
HANSOL: Smells bad.
ETHAN: It smells like
grilled artichoke.
LEALIA: Potatoes and death.
IKE: Like a rotten rose.
PHIL: Old cabbage
into a juicer.
JOHN DOLHUN: The acid chlorides
can be quite dangerous.
ROO-RA: During lecture today,
he's like, yeah, if you inhale
too much of this.
JOHN DOLHUN: If you breath
enough of them and get them
inside of your system, whoosh.
ROO-RA: And we were
all like, ugh.
JASON: I know it's coming
from my hood.
If that's what you want
me to say, yeah.
It's coming from my hood.
I'm sorry that the acetyl
chloride that we're working
with smells like death.
JOHN DOLHUN: Woosh.
GUEST SPEAKER: All the groups
complete the reaction and are
working out their finished
products.
DAN: We were seeing the things
precipitating, change color,
and separate into layers.
Me and my partner Hansol, we
were doing it fantastically.
It was going perfectly.
Until we were right
about to finish.
And all we were doing was simply
getting the crystals
out of solution.
And that's when we really,
really messed up.
TENGFEI: Did you filter the
sodium sulfate out for
[INAUDIBLE]?
DAN: No.
TENGFEI: What?
DAN: In the procedure, we
simply skipped the line.
Skipped the line that
says, filter.
The product crystallized
into a goop.
And the drying agent was still
in there in just one large,
stinky, yellow goop.
HANSOL: Oh.
[BLEEP]
DAN: OK, so how do
we save this?
PHIL: Now they have to go back
and do another work up and
extraction.
TENGFEI: There's no way to get
the sodium sulfate out.
PHIL: Not out of
the penicillin.
GUEST SPEAKER: They have
to backtrack and
redo several steps.
PHIL: It's going to add another
half hour, hour onto
their work load.
DAN: During the process
of reacidification, we
added too much acid.
Penicillin hydrolyzed.
And so the NMR spectrum of
it, we had absolutely no
penicillin peaks.
So the 4 and 1/2 hours in the
lab, we ended up with crystals
of essentially nothing.
GUEST SPEAKER: Meanwhile, other
groups are doing well.
IKE: The white stuff
is the crystal.
That's the product.
That's exactly what we want.
PHIL: People have really
good samples.
LINA: This lab went
really well.
ANTHONY: Phil said it's going
take 2 and 1/2 hours if you an
expert chemist.
And we're on our second
to last step.
And it's been 2 and 1/2 hours.
So bam.
He says he does all of this
in 2 and 1/2 hours.
Bad Beep.
But he also said that he
would run a column too.
LINA: Don't you feel like you're
really learning things
as you go along?
IKE: From her.
She's a monster.
She's just goes [INAUDIBLE].
We're the first group
to get done.
Thank you very much.
LINA: No, thank you.
High five.
IKE: [INAUDIBLE] good partner.
Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: Everyone's
excited to see whose brand of
penicillin will be the
best antibiotic.
Find out next time on 5.301.
[MUSIC PLAYING]